your brothers and sisters in the slum
net from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawa Center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah
azzawajal would give you even
I said that you know for from a Muslim
perspective the question that we're
asked to ask is bring the evidence yeah
if I were to bring reasonable evidence
which would satisfy some kind of
probabilistic reasoning that the Prophet
Muhammad
we believe is the final Prophet right
that he was a true Prophet would you be
willing to become a Muslim
I wouldn't
um
dispute a priority the idea that
Muhammad was a true prophet
but I don't understand what that means
it's like obviously so this is the way
I'm going to look at this
psychologically again you know it's
people are granted Revelations and it's
obviously the case let's speak
empirically that the revelation of
Muhammad United a fractious Society
and so it was a uniting revelation now
how to conceptualize but it's not a
universally uniting Revelation at least
not yet or not now because we're not all
United so
why maybe we didn't understand the
Revelation but it's a possibility is the
presupposition what you're saying that
Unity is the ultimate objective
well not exactly you know because then
you have the problem of uniformity that
you you know even the idea of unity
itself I mean well we talked about okay
so Unity is a great just to be clear
yeah I believe that Unity is a great
objective yeah but I don't think it's
the old defining one for example
um if there's a if there is an injustice
that is so great that disunity is more
appropriate than I can imagine
situations where this Unity is probably
better than Unity right I'm sure you can
as well for example like that would be a
false Unity yes exactly so that's what
that's why you wanted to address the
elephant under the yeah yeah but wait
because you can't have a false piece
exactly and we can't incorporate things
we can't yet incorporate yes the reason
why I'm bringing this to your attention
is because I feel like it's my duty as a
Muslim especially in the Moscow to to
tell you that
um as Muslims we believe that the
previous dispensations as they were like
Christianity and Judaism they are part
of our faith in a sense not in the sense
of believing the doctrines and all of
that kind of thing like we obviously
don't believe in original sin or the
Resurrection the crucifixion all this
kind of things we don't believe in any
of that or the Trinity of course
um but in the sense that we do believe
in Jesus Christ we believe in all of the
Old Testament prophets most of them if
not all of them you know Abraham Moses
Jesus and so on and we believe that each
Prophet was sent with two things the
message which is to Believe In Worship
in one God and some kind of evidence to
indicate their truthfulness
so with for example Moses and Jesus we
know what their miracles are splaying
the scene and we believe that actually
happened historically right we have no
qualms with that we don't have this kind
of materialistic viewpoint on the issue
uh with Muhammad we believe that his
because he was sent to All of humanity
he had to have a an Evidence base that
would satisfy not just the eyes in other
words it wouldn't be just something that
could be witnessed it would be something
that can be interrogated and scrutinized
for all times and places so it would be
an auditory of Revelation in this case
it's the Quran the Quran means a
recitation yeah so the central message
of the Quran is or the idea of
worshiping one God and believing in one
God as we've mentioned
but there are some there is an attempt
in the Quran
to challenge like for example there's
something called the falsification test
or the inevitability test the Quran says
for example that try and find a
contradiction within the Quran had it
been from other than God
we're found in many contradictions
it's this inevitability challenge is to
produce something as sophisticated as it
in terms of the linguistic composition
as well as the structural component
um this is very interesting because now
even Western academics like Angelica
nuris and others have said that this
this challenge has not been met it's a
German orientalist she's recently said
this
um so this is another thing and then you
have a range of prophecies for example
like if you look at the Deuteronomy
chapter 18 verse 21. it's mentioned in
the Bible that one of the mock Hallmarks
of a true Prophet is that or a false
prophet is that when they talk about the
future that it will be false well the
Quran makes very specific very specific
prophecies about the future for example
in Chapter 30 verse 2 to 4 it says
that the Romans had been defeated at
that time there was assassinate Empire
in the Roman Empire and they were in war
with each other and that from three to
nine years that they would defeat the
enemy you see it gave very specific
timelines it gave very specific and this
was a very risky type of uh prediction
because if you got it wrong then it
would endanger and undermine the entire
propheth or the prophet Muhammad but it
did happen in fact you'll find
Historical things which I'm not even in
the Quran Rome was defeated that wrong
no the the Persians sorry that the
Romans had been defeated by the Persians
in a battle Yeah uh and so that's it's
mentioned for example The Chronicles of
theophanes which is a primary source
material outside of the Quran
um you can find it now it's even
translated into English he he clearly
mentions that eight years after this
particular prediction took place it did
happen like that so we have a range of
predictions even that relate to the
current day the prophet said that the
the barefooted Arab because there will
be uh competing for the highest building
that's actually transmitted diseases
would be proliferated as a result of
people having intercourse outside of
marriage and that this would be
something that would be diseases that
had never been there in the past uh the
interest rate interest based
economy that we live in is mentioned by
the proper house I said in the future
interests will be everywhere
whoever does not consume it he will not
be able to evade his dust
so this is another thing so for example
um you've got a range of prophecies
where Islam will spread country by
country where you know this is mentioned
he's going to go uh there's a Hadith
that the Earth has been expanded for me
foreign
and my nation will reach
it's uh points what was projected and
it's in east and west if you look at the
Islamic expansion
I mean Barnaby Rogerson yeah who is a
historian he said that the similitude of
the Muslims going Eastward and Westward
and conquering the amount of countries
that they conquered in that early period
which you can read in the book that I've
given you is like Eskimos taken over
Russia and America
that's what he said Barnaby Richardson
on the point of prophecies even people
like Edward Gibbons they agree that the
Prophecies of the Quran had been met so
I have to ask yeah so I don't I don't I
don't understand the question exactly he
wants to know if you convert to Islam no
I'm saying that no that wasn't I mean
that's the question well look I would
say to some degree it's not up to me
none of us but my question was just to
remind you the question was if I gave
you evidence that would satisfy a
certain level of probabilistic no
no because that isn't how I evaluate the
situation how would you evaluate that
well I'm a Muslim enough to have been
invited to your mosque no are you always
invited
I mean this specific yeah I mean this
very specifically you know
um I don't think in some sense
this is a very complicated problem okay
you know when when people meet me on the
street they'll say things like I met a
couple of Orthodox Jews in New York and
they said to me on the street that they
call me Rabbi which was
it's a hell of a thing to hear